oh
o o
[Musique]
michel roussin ce décor vous va
parfaitement je trouve
parce que vous êtes un homme de pouvoir
mais vous aimez le pouvoir dans l'ombre
vous l'avez exercé avec trois hommes
derrière trois hommes monsieur alexandre
de marenches patron du sdec avec jacques
chirac et avec vincent bolloré
pourquoi avoir choisi cette ombre je
pense que ça donne beaucoup plus
d'aisance pour pouvoir assumer les
responsabilités qui vous sont donnés oui
je pense que être dans l'ombre
ça ne veut pas dire craindre quoi que ce
soit mais ça permet une plus grande
initiative une plus grande souplesse
pour cette prochaine
pardon plus efficace et à mon sens plus
efficace parce que ça vous permet
d'avoir toujours une réserve et ça vous
permet de pouvoir réagir le moment venu
et de ne pas être coincé dans une espèce
de spectacle permanent
je trouve que cette discrétion m'a
toujours servi sauf que celui qui est
normalement première ligne il prend les
coups et vous vous en avez pris les
coups alors vous étiez pas en première
ligne même si à un moment vous avez été
ministre de la coopération
on peut prendre les coups mais quand on
a là la culture que j'ai à la base qui
est une culture un air de bien de
militaires et ensuite dans mes activités
au sein de la défense j'ai commencé très
tôt dans les services plus tard j'ai été
repéré par alexandre de marenches mais
il ya un fil conducteur
donc c'est pour moi une seconde une
seconde nature encore d'être dans ce
comportement là alors on encaisse les
coups
mais on a la possibilité peut-être de
résister mieux que d'autres
ah oui vous savez où est la limite je ne
pense pas qu'on peut savoir où est la
limite mais on a on soit la ressource
nécessaire pour tenir le coup alors il
ya un homme justement vous avez cité son
nom qui a participé au début de votre
carrière qui s'appelle alexandre de
marenches qui était le patron du sdec
des renseignements extérieurs de la
france
maintenant c'est la dgs vous avez été
avec lui
quelle est la limite pour peut-être
barbus pour pas devenir barbouzes enfin
ça fait fantasmer les gens ça ah oui
mais les services spéciaux c'est tout
sauf être bar blues bar blues ça fait
partie de la du vocabulaire
cinématographique du roman et espionnage
etc
là c'est autre chose c'est défendre les
intérêts du pays contre des attaques
venant de l'extérieur et alexandre de
marenches tu assez mûrs en voyant ce
visage que j'ai côtoyés pendant sept ans
n'avait qu'une idée en tête c'est de
préserver les intérêts de la france et
quand on préserve les intérêts de la
france est ce qu'on peut aller jusque
dans l'illégalité
je pense et on se doit d'aller dans
l'illégalité c'est à ça que servent les
services bien évidemment néanmoins il y
a toujours un contrôle de l'exécutif et
on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
toujours un contrôle
il ya un contrôle de vue des affaires
quand même la sphère rainbow warrior la
sphère la sphère du rainbow warrior à la
voient pas la réalité mais une
autorisation avait été donnée par la
présidence de la république
ensuite les modalités d'exécution de
l'opération foire ça arrive
vous avez déjà devient un scandale vous
avez déjà dit non à marange alexandre de
marenches quand il vous a dit j'aimerais
que vous fassiez ça jamais parce que ça
a toujours été dans dans la limite de ce
qui était réalisable
et si cet homme l'a été pendant douze
ans le patron des services français
c'est que l'exécutif les exécutifs
successifs ont trouvé que l'homme défend
des
la république du mieux qu'ils pouvaient
vous êtes ému quand vous parlez de lire
oui parce que je lui dois énormément je
g t ag était à matignon sous trois
premiers ministres chaban-delmas messmer
1 2 3 et jacques chirac
et pendant cette période là j'ai été le
correspondant du sdec je suis parti
ailleurs quand chirac a quitté le
gouvernement et alexandre de marenches
qui avait suivi mon activité au sein du
cabinet du premier ministre est venu me
récupérer à la préfecture de tours et
m'a nommé comme directeur de cabinet du
sdec quatre grosses affaires vous avez
traité
on a prêté beaucoup d'affaires
concernant les otages on a traité
beaucoup d'affaires mais alors là
c'était de la peut-être de la
géopolitique
il a essayé et avec lui ses
collaborateurs de créer autour d'eux des
idées de la france une espèce de clubs
de personnalités étrangères iraniennes
pakistanaise marocaine et c'est une
espèce de de club informel pour
réfléchir sur les sujets de notre temps
et vous avez des relations et des dix
agents secrets étrangers oui avec oui
mais pas des agents secrets mais avec
les représentants des structures alors
deuxième homme très important
jacques chirac et on dit que vous êtes
le coffre fort des secrets du
chiraquisme
vous étiez vraiment son homme sont
oblige son homme lige non mais un de ses
plus proches l'un de ses plus proches
collaborateurs
les relations étaient chaleureuses
complice parfois mais ça a toujours été
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
maire
toujours en mouvement d'accord ou jours
enfin je veux dire il n'y a jamais eu de
facilité dans nos relations
alors qu'est-ce qu'on venait chercher
c'était quelques années après que vous
ayez commencé à avoir des problèmes avec
la justice
qu'est ce qu'on va chercher dans votre
bureau à la défense en 2005 des hommes
masqués une nuit sont venus visiter
votre buron par réaction qu'est-ce qu'on
venait chercher dans ce bureau s'est
passé tête à une époque où j'étais
effectivement de nouveau embarqué dans
des affaires judiciaires alors il ya
trois affaires judiciaires il
yal'affaire des hlm de paris dans lequel
votre nom est cité il y à la faire on y
reviendra il yal'affaire des emplois
fictifs et il yal'affaire des lycées
d'île de france
il s'agit de la faire des lycées d'île
de france en l'occurrence voilà est-ce
qu'on voulait chercher dans votre bureau
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on a
tous les gens qui sont venus depuis des
années 17 ans parcours judiciaire ça
fait on va en parler
un paquet de perquisition et cetera
comment pouvait-on imaginer trouver chez
un type qui a été formé dans le
renseignement qui a été le directeur de
cabinet d' alexandre de marenches
comment pouvait-on imaginer qu'il y ait
un papelard ou quelque chose de
compromettant chez moi chaque fois j'ai
vu la déception sur le visage de ceux
qui démontent est mon appartement
ouais il n'y a jamais eu quelque chose
chez vous vous n'avez jamais eu des
aînés un dossier rien remarqué secret
rien ou avec un nom qui lui est prêté à
quelques problèmes
non ça mais ça irrite et parfois vous
êtes un homme propre jeu je pense oui
vous avez toujours voulu l'être toujours
et pourtant jacques chirac vous avez
écrit un livre sur lui d'ailleurs vous
étiez le gendarme de chirac
oui il n'a pas vous les avez dit tout à
l'heure il y avait une distance entre
nous il n'a pas toujours été tendre avec
vous non mais écoutez je crois que j'ai
une explication je peux la donne est
maintenant parce que alors avec les
années le recul je me dis que je suis un
collaborateur de quelqu'un qui a en lui
la volonté le la
gnac pour devenir président de la
république française
donc on est quelques-uns autour de lui à
accompagner ce qui va être une bataille
incessante jusqu'à ce qu'il soit élu
président de la république
si vous êtes vous le caillou dans la
chaussure
pendant la progression de celui qui veut
atteindre ce but là vous devenez un
dommage collatéral et vous avez ce que
je lui ai reproché c'est effectivement
de ne m'avoir plus comme comme disaient
les jeux a produit vous a passé le plus
laid vous a pas soutenu donc d'écouter
ça vous a été secouée choqué par la mise
en examen et surtout l'incarcération de
michel roussin qui fut votre
collaborateur
en toute hypothèse c'est ça a toujours
été ma position il ne saurait y avoir
d'amnesty ça c'est clair
je le dis parce qu'on en a parlé on ne
traite pas ces problèmes par la voix de
l'est misty ou de je ne sais quel ennui
repentance à le françois fillon avec les
politiques étaient un peu hypocrite
rennes est passé problème de cette
manière
s'il n'y a eu des choses condamnables
elles doivent être condamnés c'est rude
ça quand même
oui parle de vous et c'est d'alinghi et
et moi j'encaisse et j'encaisse reset
allart 1 jusqu'au moment où lui-même
sera enfin il n'est plus chef de l'état
il n'est plus présent il sera à son tour
condamné
enfin vous dites je vous souhaitiez
jeudi enfin non parce que condamner peu
importe mais qu'ils aient assumé ses
responsabilités il y en avait il en
avait d'ailleurs il a finalement accepté
et il a fait cette déclaration qui
finalement a permis à un certain nombre
de ses collaborateurs d'obtenir une
relaxe d'accord et pourquoi vous avez
marché dans tous ces histoires hlm de
paris on reparlera du fonds après hlm de
paris lycées d'ile-de-france emplois
fictifs
de toute façon compte tenu le
de la responsabilité que j'avais
nécessairement j'étais dans le
dispositif est donc pour les magistrats
la solution de facilité c'est de se
choisir la personnalité peut être
fragile qui va craquer parce que sa
notoriété son image et c est ça a été ça
sans arrêt je suis j'ai rencontré 14
juges d'instruction différents et dans
deux dames dont je voyais aussi à la fin
des entretiens le fond un fondre parce
que l'énervement les éternelles
questions les mêmes et moi toujours les
mêmes réponses
vous savez ce que disait la bruyère
quand on est le collaborateur d'un
puissant il s'en tire toujours et vous
vous payez pour lui et pour vous même à
la bruyère
là en l'occurrence cette incitation
magnifique
ouais il a raison parce que vous faisiez
plein de choses et pour jacques chirac
oui moi que vous avez raconté que vous
sortiez même le chien chien claude non
ça c'était une société d'une boutade
mais par contre j'ai utilisé des amitiés
dans les armées pour permettre aux
chirac de mettre leur chien dans un
chenil militaire pendant leurs vacances
pas promener le chien mais néanmoins
effectivement je me suis occupé de ces
animaux domestiques si sympa vous
devenez ministre de la coopération en
1993 lors de la deuxième cohabitation
d'edouard balladur
est ce que vous pensez vous avez été
victimes de la guerre que se livraient
ces deux hommes c'est un secret pour
personne
de la jalousie qui se portait l'un
l'autre peut-être mais genève je n'ai
pas de deux points très particulier qui
mais marquez qui puisse me permettent
d'illustrer ce que vous venez de dire
néanmoins si j'ai été nommé ministre
chirac était bien d'accord avec edouard
balladur nom de la formation du
gouvernement
quelques temps plus tard chirac sur les
affaires de l'afrique qui était de mon
ressort
me convoque à l'hôtel de ville et et me
demande de lui dire un peu ce qui se
passe et cetera critiquent la politique
du gouvernement et me demande de prendre
position
ce que je refuse en lui disant mais
monsieur je suis ministre du
gouvernement je suis le collaborateur
d'edouard balladur dans le sens
contraire vous et tente vous accepteriez
qu'un de vos collaborateurs passent donc
et il m'a dit à ce moment-là ça je m'en
souviens et ça m'avait marqué michel
vous n'avez pas de colonne vertébrale il
s'apercevra plus tard car je le lui
écrirai et lui me répondra que j'ai une
colonne vertébrale mais ça ça m'avait
beaucoup marqué donc et vous avez dit
sortez aussi non non il m'a pas dit
sortez mais je le pensais oui c'était la
même chose quand vous dites vous avez
laissé vous connaissez depuis toujours
vous n'avez pas de colonne vertébrale
c'est insupportable
il ya un homme qui pour lequel vous
n'avez pas beaucoup d'amitié non plus
dans l'entourage de jacques chirac alors
il ya peut-être une jalousie comme vous
vous étiez proche de lui c'est alain
juppé non plus non non c'est pas nous
sommes deux caractère tout à fait
différent et ministre des affaires
étrangères d'ailleurs du coup il été
mise en place et du rejet et vous à la
coopération dans wii et terrain oui ce
qui était très important pour le
ministre de la coopération et ce qui
énervait un peu le département ce que
j'ai été un ministre de plein exercice
pas ministre délégué pas secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre plein voilà
et ça ça va énerver beaucoup et quand il
y avait une réunion de cabinet
aux affaires étrangères parce qu'on a
toujours des copains qui vous téléphone
après quand il y avait la réunion de
cabinet aux affaires étrangères et que
nous nous étions au conseil des
ministres quand on rentrait il y avait
toujours quelqu'un qui me disait tu as
peu de chance on a encore parlé de doigt
le intéressant dans à 10 mai ou par
encore ce contreseing c'est juppé qui 10
h non parce qu'il est au conseil des
ministres avec moi mais c'est au sein de
son cabinet donc il y avait cette espèce
de de vie difficile aux visions de du
pouvoir différentes sûrement sûrement le
rôle du ministre des affaires étrangères
est un rôle essentiel celui de la
coopération à l'époque était était un
rôle important mais si vous voulez dans
la hiérarchie des membres du
gouvernement car de sa mécanique le miz
la coopération et les 13e et le ministre
des affaires étrangères est à un autre
niveau
non donc eux avaient leurs contraintes
et pour éviter les chicaillas on a
décidé que chaque fois que je partirai
en afrique il y aurait à mes côtés un
représentant du cabinet du ministre des
affaires vous suivrai quand même il me
suivait vous n'avez jamais revu alain
juppé non si dans les affaires mais non
je les voyais jamais non non on ne sait
jamais jamais croisés on n'était pas
dans les mêmes juridictions d'accord ne
dépendez pas trois affaires trois
affaires avec une justice qui a été pour
vous impitoyable et des médias qui ont
peut-être été si on regarde bien si on
objectif ce qui est difficile pour un
journaliste
mais ingrat 17 ans de procédure
oui 17 ans ça s'est terminé en 2008 avec
un arrêt de la cour de cassation qui
refuse d'ailleurs votre pourvoi comment
vous avez vécu ses 17 ans là je crois
que c'est une bataille et il faut se
préparer à cette bataille
ensuite c'est un truc de coureur de fond
c'est à dire que vous avez donc vos
adversaires qui sont les juges qui n'ont
qu'une idée en tête le concernant c'est
que je cite jacques chirac que je mette
en cause le secrétaire général du rpr
que or ils n'y arriveront jamais vous
êtes apte et e
je pense oui et que parfois il faut
l'être
ça ne m'empêche pas d'avoir un côté je
suis originaire d'afrique du nord de
rabat rabat ça ne m'empêche pas d'être
je suis peut-être t e mais je sais aussi
participé à une réunion m'amuser
discuter raconter des histoires et
inventeur sa jeune et quand on quand il
s'agit de ces choses là quand il s'agit
de des affaires très importante qui
concerne la république voilà il faut
savoir raison garder et puis d'avoir une
attitude et n'ont jamais se départir
jusqu'à ressentir qu'on est humiliée
vous avez dit un jour je crois si chirac
savait ce que c'est qu'une fouille au
corps
oui payer pour lui oui mais ça c'est ça
c'est un souvenir qui est qui et qui
cuisent en 1 et toute cette manip si
vous voulez c'est pour faire craquer le
bonhomme
parce que cette incarcération n'a pas
duré car mes avocats ont tout de suite
fait part de leur étonnement rappeler
quelques règles et la porte de la santé
s'est de nouveau verte c'était un coupon
rien de la part des magistrats
d'ailleurs je me demande quelle quelle
vie ils ont là je regardais comme je me
disais que peut-être on en parlerait
google on voit on voit tout sur google
alors pas que j'ai pris quelques noms
comme ça et je crois que j'ai eu une vie
plus intéressante que parce que c'est
finalement vous regagnez passes sont à
la retraite et vous avez des choses à
raconter c'est ça
oui et puis j'ai j'ai une vie ça a
marché j'ai fait autre chose soutenu
pendant cette période par vos amis au
gouvernement qui était au gouvernement
ou au rpr à l'ump
non mais il faut les comprendre aussi
nice et si rod à tout le monde à tout le
monde a une petite crainte dans dix ans
mais quand mengue unique qu'est ce qui
va faire et il voulait maintenant ça va
se passer
vous permettez un mot actuel voulait
même que vous dégagiez parce que maître
szpiner qui était le conseiller de
jacques chirac à venelles imaginez que
vous puissiez fuir maroc à lui pas lui
lui n'a été que le porteur du message
d'ailleurs il se trompait
d'interlocuteur il aurait dû avoir un
peu plus le sens de la psychologie et
bien évidemment ce message
samassa m'a beaucoup étonné bien
évidemment être que dire je n'en ai rien
fait oui j'ai dit que vous étiez un
homme de l'ombre même si vous avez été
ministre de la coopération pleine
lumière pendant un moment
est ce que on peut gouverner sans ombre
aujourd'hui le mot clé c'est la
transparence
est-ce qu'on peut gouverner sans ombre
alors je n'ai pas été à des postes tels
que je puisse euh oui mais vous les avez
vus mais je mets jugé vue j'ai toujours
été sur un strapontin
j'ai vu les choses se passer lorsque
j'étais chez jacques chaban delmas où
chez pierre messmer de premier ministre
tout à fait différent l'un et l'autre
avaient effectivement part sur certains
sujets une part d'ombré
il faut une part d'ombré pour gouverner
à moi j'en suis convaincu et aujourd'hui
parce que là la transparence c'est
quelque chose de cet ami tu parce qu'il
n'a jamais vraiment totalement de
transparence ce que l'homme n'est pas un
être transparent le bonhomme lui même
donc on ne peut pas penser que tout peut
se traiter dans la transparence et vous
êtes transparent avec moi non oui mais
cachez pas non mais parce qu'on est dans
un contexte particulier et
rien de grave n'est en cause alors que
lorsqu'il s'agit de gouverner l'état ou
de prendre des décisions importantes
dans le cadre d'une municipalité ou
d'une collectivité etc
il ya chaque fois avant de prendre une
décision
voilà tout dire alors il ya un continent
qui vous tient au coeur c'est l'afrique
l'afrique
vous allez très régulièrement vous êtes
avez toute votre vie quasiment en
afrique si je puis dire et vous
continuer à y travailler
on va avoir une image qui vous montre je
crois que c'est en haute volta annonce
et ça c'est voltaire je veux dire
burkina faso plus tard le drapeau et le
drapeau du burkina faso et ça parce que
aux pays des hommes intègres pays des
hommes intègres
parce que cette locomotive que qu'on
vient d'acheter suis le président de
sita rails
j'ai quitté cette présidence il ya il ya
un an et demi j'ai fait marcher ce train
pendant 12 ans pendant que les juges
gratte route ça fait marcher les trains
c'est drôle pas mal pourquoi l'afrique
pourquoi l'afrique parce que assez tôt
chez alexandre de marenches j'ai été
parfois associées à des sujets qui
concernait l'afrique
à l'époque c'était la poussée de l'urss
en afrique après quoi c'est pas un
perdreau de l'année est ouest voilà et
donc là le service avait une vraie
responsabilité il fallait suivre nos
adversaires et savoir comment réagissent
et nos partenaires africains devant la
pression donc je me suis intéressé à
l'afrique
à cette époque là et puis ensuite à
l'hôtel de ville
chirac avait une relation particulière
avec un certain nombre chef d'état ils
avaient mis au point ce club des pays
francophones
il aura d'ailleurs une influence
considérable pour créer un ministère de
la francophonie c'est lui jacques chirac
et mitterrand connaissait bien l'afrique
aussi mitterrand aussi mitterrand
c'était formidable avec moi
le président mitterrand moi j'étais la
première fois que je suis convoquée chez
président mitterrand qui était pour moi
le l'adversaire alors j'avais bien
réviser mes questions de court avec mon
cabinet je suis arrivé chez le président
qui m'a fait asseoir et qui m'a posé une
question assez difficile mais j'avais
bien travaillé je répond parfaitement
là dessus le président de la république
a enclenché et je me suis retrouvé
devant l'ancien ministre de la france
d'outre-mer et à partir de ce moment là
chaque fois que j'ai eu une réunion chez
le président de la république
chez le président mitterrand il y avait
une question d'actualité et très
rapidement l'homme était fatigué c'était
la deuxième cohabitation etc
j'avais l'impression que c'était un peu
une détente que d'avoir le jeune
ministre de la coopération qui
découvraient les choses et il m'a
raconté il raconté mais des aventures
extraordinaires avec des messages
politiques importants qui m'ont été très
utile et c'était aller pour rêver après
mitterrand j'ai appris mitterrand
absolument sternum de coups tordus
pourtant parfois un homme de coups
tordus
un homme avec sa part d'ombré et c'est
tout ce que nous disions précédemment et
une petite anecdote
oui je lui demande un jour si je peux
prendre des notes et alors une 18e
monsieur le ministre
prenez des notes on m'a dit que vous
êtes une barbe rouge mais vous aimez
bien les africains oui vous disais ça
donc ça a calmé le jeu et un jour il dit
mais vous prenez des notes lui même
monsieur le président vous m'avez
autorisés à prendre des notes
oui ma chère au 5 mai
manger nos blocs changer de bloc parce
qu'il avait vu que mon bloc-notes était
aux armes de la ville de paris rouge et
bleu avec la nef aimé y voit la petite
anecdote quand vous avez un rapport
comme ça avec le président de la
république
vous vous dites que à la prochaine 1 au
prochain entretien vous pourrez vous
exprimer vous pourrez solliciter un avis
vous pourrez alors l'afrique l'afrique
c'est le continent aussi ou faut pas se
le cacher il ya de la corruption
oui mais il ya des choses pas très
avouables bien sûr vous arrivez à y
travailler sont en échappant à tous
alors le ca il faut l'avoir en
permanence en mémoire et savoir qu'en
dépit des efforts qui sont faits par les
africains pour trouver une organisation
qui soit plus compatible avec les règles
internationales et cetera il faut une
volonté politique
il y arrive pas partout mais des efforts
considérables ont été faits on ne peut
pas plaquer les règles européennes et
donc française au monde africain
soyons des partenaires la période de la
colonie est loin derrière nous les les
pays sont indépendants depuis 1960
laissons les africains s'organiser
accompagnons l'est mais pas d'ingérence
dans les affaires africaines
le pouvoir peut être vertueux le pouvoir
peut être vertueux
le pouvoir peut être vertueux ou peu
tendre à le devenir à condition que on
accompagne ses efforts et dans le
domaine des activités économiques
là aussi nous devons avoir nous les
européens parce que je considère que
l'afrique c'est l'avenir de l'europe si
l'europe va pas vers l'afrique l'europe
va être ghetto y fier parce que tout va
se passer maintenant en afrique et donc
il faut travailler avec les africains
être patient comprendre trouver des
objectifs communs vous pouvez pas
arriver en disant je suis monsieur
alstom
réécoutez le train urbain 2 c'est pour
moi on est très loin car voilà terminé
d'ailleurs pour le système faux car moi
j'ai tout de suite dit quand on a essayé
de me mettre dans mon cabinet des gens
de la tribu faux car j'ai dit non
d'ailleurs jacques chirac m'a convoqué
en disant mais commencer c'est de la
rébellion
je lui dis c'est pas de la rébellion
c'est le cabinet qui doit être différent
puisque on entame une nouvelle politique
en afrique j'ai j'ai eu à ce moment là
des difficultés avec le le clan foccart
mais je les ai bien géré merci michel
roussin merci
[Musique]